foreign
because she's been keeping money secret
from me and spending lots of amount of
money without me knowing so the way I
couch that is financial infidelity she's
cheating on you she's lying to you
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
baloney show the greatest
marriage and relationships the mental
health podcast ever recorded
and my friends tell me I speak mostly in
Hyperbole and I disagree so glad you're
with us uh if you want to be on the show
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask tons of Shenanigans in the news
we'll get to a little bit later here
um it's a rare that I get I almost never
uh talk about the news on this show but
um in a directed way but man
leave it to the uh news media
particularly one [ __ ] in particular to
just
just knock it out of the park but we'll
get to that later all right let's go
let's first let's go to Taylor and
Milwaukee what's up Taylor
hi Dr John how are you good what are you
doing
oh you know partying yes excellent It's
like 10 in the morning I'm I'm excellent
we should probably talk about that yeah
that may be another call but we can talk
about that
what are you up to having fun
oh it's it's a whole Adventure that
we're having over here oh tell me about
it
um so my siblings and I are kind of at a
Crossroads we are trying to figure out
how to maintain uh
relationship with our parents
um they have a hoarding issue and now
it's becoming in health concerned and
we're wondering how we can help them
stay well while still respecting their
things and respecting their space
oh that's hard and I know you know that
tell me before I jump into that tell me
some of the challenges y'all
tell me some of the things you've tried
to do let me ask that way
um to be honest over the last few years
we've
been pretty laissez-faire about it and
then we've known that this has been an
issue that they've both had throughout
our entire lives okay
um but it's recently come to light that
my dad has congestive heart failure and
she's going in for a triple bypass so
it's become more of a a priority to give
him a clean healing space to recover
that's safe for him to move around
without worrying about tripping or
slipping
and the challenge with
um hoarding is that safety comes from
that environment the perceived the
perception of safety right
and so in order to make somebody like
truly safe you've got to make their feel
very unsafe
um how's your mom responded to this not
well I'm assuming
not well uh we did go up there about a
week ago and we started cleaning out uh
one of the bedrooms
three of us about six hours and that
probably didn't go well did it
how'd you know what because I've I've
sat with hoarders before it's very
challenging
um I've helped I've helped people get
stuff out of their homes before it's
very very challenging
um yeah that's tough tough tough tell me
about it
[Music]
random pieces of furniture random
clothing tons and tons of hygiene
products
um my brother came down with a covered
trailer it was a seven by ten and we
completely filled it out of one bedroom
um Dad was pretty on board with it uh
there were a couple of things that they
both asked us to keep so we try to be as
respectful as possible and set those
things off to the side
um Dad was pretty on board with getting
things cleaned up there were a couple of
things that you could tell were harder
for him to let go of but Mom seemed to
struggle with it more so we were trying
to push the
idea that this is this isn't about your
things we're not just trying to you know
come over and wipe you out and take all
of your stuff but this is about Dad's
health right now and that's obviously
much bigger than any tangible thing you
can hold in this world right and
it seemed to sink in a little bit and
then an hour later we would be right
back to square a that's right that's
right I my guess would be just based off
that one little snippet um has your
mother been the driver
has she been the one over time
accumulating things dealing with anxiety
dealing with this internal stress by
just accumulating and accumulating and
your dad just kind of lived in it
um and then it became part of their
world
the anxious quarter like you had said
and I feel like Dad is more of a
gracious quarter where if he buys things
of the intention of giving them to
people and then they get lost in the mix
and they just sit there right both of
those you have better intentions both so
go ahead as you work through this
you have um are looking at this very
logically okay and fear and panic and
anxiety those are very illogical systems
they don't your brain doesn't want you
logically wondering how kind or nice
that tiger is at the front of the door
it just wants you to get out of there
right so it screams at you it sounds all
your alarms and you get out of town
right then you come to find out that
that tiger is actually your neighbor's
tiger and it's super sweet has no claws
no teeth and it's just lovely right who
cares your brain said tiger I'm out of
here right so you've heard of fight
flight or freeze as trauma responses as
the things that your body does to get
you out of a situation stress response
there's also a fourth one called Fawn
where you nuzzle up you
um maybe if I am extra loving extra
close
that will help ease this anxiety I feel
in this relationship
and so your mother may have one impulse
that is I'm going to accumulate in case
for out of scarcity
um I saw that they were in a toilet
paper they may run out of sun I mean
soap and deodorant and all these things
right and then all of a sudden the
trains out of the station and your dad
may be doing something similar where his
anxiety is I'm gonna try to bridge the
gap between relationships and instead of
sitting down in a rocking chair and just
saying I love you tell me about your day
I'm going to buy stuff I'm going to buy
stuff I'm gonna buy stuff he never
actually gets around giving it away but
it's always this idea that this is some
altruistic motive it's not really really
they're both the same impulse and that's
covering up a brain that is screaming
for that we're not safe we're not safe
we're not safe and that's what makes
cleaning up so hard is your logical
brain the part of your head that says
this could all tip over on me and I'm
gonna die or the one that could do the
math and say I could open a new bar of
soap every day for the rest of my life
I'm only going to live 20 more years
that's this many more days I have that
much soap in my home this is this is
madness but you try to get rid of that
soap and your body turns all the alarm
systems on and it's very hard so your
mother is actually trying to do a Noble
thing which is I hear you I trust you
and then just an hour later her brain is
like ah it's all going like they're
peeling back all of our layers of safety
which makes this really hard
um
so
your situation is I don't say it's rare
but it's not one that everybody's gonna
um run into
but what something everybody is going to
run into is
we need to have some hard conversations
and some boundary conversations with our
parents about finances about safety
about their mental health about whatever
and how do we do that
um ultimately I think you are 100
correct your dad cannot go back to a
home that is
um
unsafe and it's unsafe both structurally
but it's also unsafe the rats and mice
that will live in that stuff and they
haven't found any evidence of their
presence yes exactly I mean so you pile
that much stuff anywhere and rats and
mice are going to live in there and he
can't breathe that
um the infection risk all of that so the
question you and your siblings need to
ask is this
um
yeah
how far are we willing to go
and to keep Dad safe versus let him ride
out his last days how he wants to
what I mean is there may come a moment
when you have to call notify the social
worker at the hospital that's going to
talk to him about his release and you
need to let that person know that his
current home is unsafe and either he has
to go to a home or your mother has to
allow a team to come in there and clean
that thing top to bottom and that
usually involves one or two of those big
dumpsters get dropped off in the front
yard and a team will go in there and
just take everything and get the carpets
redone or clean or new carpet paint the
walls like the house is going to need to
be
um really overhauled so that he's safe
um
short that you're talking about we're
just going to nickel and dime this thing
and that room will fill back up with
junk the because you're really you're
not getting the core issue the core
issue is not the stuff
the core issue is your mom and dad
aren't well and now they're getting to
an age where their Wellness is kind of
rolling back on you right
correct so how far are y'all willing to
go
um I mean we're pretty deep into it mom
has been pretty good about letting a
couple of my siblings come over because
they live pretty far away from all of us
so we're all just trying to tag teams as
far as when we can make it up there to
do some cleaning here there in between
our own lives and schedules and work and
families and things like that
um
but as far as like
I guess we don't really know what all
the options are like we've kind of taken
this on as we have to figure this out
and we have a very short amount amount
of time to do this
um my two sisters are coming up from
Texas for his surgery
um which was recently put off for
another couple of weeks which is almost
a godsend if he is stable enough to like
for that couple weeks for us to have
more time to to handle this and figure
this out because yeah we're kind of all
in a Mad Dash will anybody would anybody
take him in for a month
I don't know if any of us could to be
honest like I live two hours away in a
one bedroom apartment the bathroom is on
a separate level than the rest of the
living yeah so I don't know if that
would work for him I I don't know if my
brother and his family could do it okay
ultimately here's the framework for
making the decision
you and your siblings right now y'all
trying to nickel and dime this thing and
quite honestly it's probably not going
to work
it might you might create a single
bedroom with some space in it and that's
cool my guess is
um especially with folks who collect
hygiene Pro like the best the bathroom's
wild is that fair
it was before I cleaned it last weekend
well done very good
um
there were lots of clubs involved yes if
you don't deal with that core issue it
will just refill itself
and it'll have clothes in there and
ironing boards and stuff that doesn't I
mean that you wouldn't traditionally put
in a bathroom it's just gonna fill up
that way the framework here is this how
far are we going to let Dad back in that
house yes or no
if the answer is yes under what
parameters
if we're not going to let them back in
there are we all in a position is he in
a position to pay for a one-bedroom
apartment he can live in while he heals
for six months just on a six-month lease
will one of us take him in do we have
money to pitch in and get him a rehab
home right this is a matter of hey we're
all like willing to get dirty and
aggressive and all this
there's a much bigger issue at play here
that much much deeper reality here that
I think everybody's got to deal with the
other thing that you can't miss is this
you got a brother and a sister is that
right
okay okay so there's actually a chunk of
folks that's great
um the five of you are grieving this
yourselves too
because Dad's having that's scary for
anybody's Dad to have that that level of
surgery for Mom not to be well to have
to go in there and see this stuff in
your parents home these kind of things
bring up junk in all of us too and if
you don't deal with that then the
exercise of cleaning becomes the uh
anesthetic that becomes the Xanax it
becomes the thing we do to cover over
the pain
instead of getting to that root cause
and dealing with it and so
I think there just needs to be a zoom
call of some sort for all your brothers
and if your brother and your sisters
everybody get on the same page and you
can lead it and
wonder what conditions do we let Dad
move back in if I say let him move in
he's a grown-up he can maybe do what he
wants to but we're going to make a
formal Report with the social worker and
say his living environment is not safe
somebody needs to do a welfare check is
the words on his home and see if
somebody if he should be allowed to move
back in and my guess is they would say
absolutely not and then can any of us
take him for 30 days or 60 days in our
homes yes it's going to be inconvenient
but he's our dad right
does he have the money do you all have
the money to pitch in and get him a six
month lease at a small apartment well
you all continue to drive back and forth
to nickel and dimness or will your mom
sit down and have a really hard
conversation which is we're about to
pull the trigger on all this stuff or
we're going to hire a crew to come in
there and take care of your home
and maybe she's found some peace in that
bathroom she's found some peace in that
bedroom that didn't exist previously
that'd be fantastic if she did my guess
is probably not it's probably very
stressful for her to go in there but
maybe not
um
but man she did that'd be fantastic then
you could hire a crew get in there and
get that stuff cleaned out over a
weekend and everybody pitches in four or
five hundred bucks that of course none
of you'll have that but you do it anyway
and then man Now We're Off to the Races
dad can come home but I think there's a
level of reality that we got to get to
and you're not the only one almost all
of us have to get to that level of
reality with our parents and say this is
actually what we're dealing with and
what decisions are we going to make
moving forward but thank you so much for
that call let me know how those talks go
I really want to follow up on this one
let me know those talks go let me know
if your mom ultimately comes around and
let me know how the surgery goes and
we'll be thinking about your dad we'll
be right back
hey what's up deloney here I've got a
word from our sponsor better help I'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way burnout is when
your body has enough and it says I'm out
I'm done it's that deep feeling of
exhaustion after a long period of being
overworked and over stressed and just
fried and most of us associate burnout
with work but burnout can happen at any
area of our lives and it can cause a
lack of motivation irritability fatigue
or randomly crying at some random song
on the radio or when somebody looks at
you the wrong way and that's why I love
my friends at better help better help
online therapy exists to give you the
chance to invest in your healing better
help is customize online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with you and your therapist you
never have to even see anyone on camera
if you don't want to it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours and today our list owners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com deloney that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go to Carlos
in oh great we're gonna go back to
Oklahoma what's up Carlos
hey how's it going Dr John good how are
you
doing doing good hanging in there even
in Oklahoma
yeah it's nice and nice and rainy out
here so is it really fine yeah man you
almost ready y'all needed that huh yeah
good deal all right what's up man
hey
um
yeah I mean I don't know I kind of don't
know where to start so I'll just kind of
get straight to the Cannonball dude hey
if you don't know how to jump in the
lake just Cannonball that's the best way
yeah there you go and so
um just something that has been
happening between
um me and my wife is simply I've I've
been I felt betrayed simply because
she's been keeping money secret from me
and spending lots of amount of money
um without me knowing and it's can it's
a continuous thing and she came back to
me about two weeks two weeks ago letting
me know about it again after you know
we've talked
um two other times you know kind of
trying to budget and all this stuff but
it just keeps happening and so I'm
feeling kind of just I don't know don't
know what to do feeling really down I
know the downside this isn't like a
money problem I feel like it's very a
lot deeper than that yeah and so with
that being said I I have like some
feelings about it because I know it's
not a money problem but I just need some
guidance need some help about certain
thoughts that like I have regarding this
issue yeah
um so dude it's it's an Integrity issue
and it's an honest honesty right and
it's a Fidelity issue
so the way I couch that is financial
infidelity she's cheating on you she's
lying to you yeah right yeah she's got
secrets and I think you're very very
wise
um
to see this the money is just the
symptom of a much bigger issue going on
um when you guys meet up tell me how
these like so you you get together to
have a budget which all all budget means
is you all have a plan for how you want
your life to go and you have some dreams
of what you want your life to look like
right so that you you reverse engineer
that all that starts with like Sunday
nights we're gonna say how are we going
to do money this week where is she
getting this pocket of money that she's
hiding from you
credit cards uh she did tell me that she
got a personal loan through her bank
which are things that I didn't know
about she just went in and did it behind
me yeah what's she buying
so that's kind of where I wanted to go
kind of just get a give you some context
so we we've been together four years
we're almost two years married now
um we went to therapy together
um while we were dating and also when we
were married but there was a hiccup
there where she didn't like therapy
anymore because she felt like the therap
the therapist and I were like teaming up
against her and stuff like that so that
kind of came tumbling down she doesn't
like accountability does she
um
I guess I I feel I feel bad this you
know I feel bad because I love my wife
and hey I I don't feel bad but I feel
I don't like talking bad about some
dude's wife right so when I ask these
questions I'm not it's not me being like
oh dude it's not like that but it's me
saying like you're married to somebody
that does not like accountability and
right feels trapped by that and really
doesn't want people telling her what to
do and you know who does that also my
six-year-old daughter
yeah it's a very immature way to to
navigate the world because it's not a
real it's not a recognition of adult
reality right right right and so go to
answer your question what she's spending
this on so after that whole hiccup with
the therapist happened
um she has friends that are
life coaches you know mindset coaches
and she expressed that you know talking
to them was like in one session helped
her more than therapy ever did and so
ever since she got started getting
involved in that she's like I want to
become one so that's what she's spending
on she says spent thousands and
thousands of dollars on courses to
become a life coach and just things like
that and so she has like
this career that she wants to get in
mind
um and like also Porter but she feels
like I don't support her when I say like
we can't buy this certain course what
I'd like to happen is let's save the
money and then when you have the money
let's go ahead and pay that like I'm all
for that but she just wants everything
now now let me get this like make sure
I'm on the right page
yes she is pursuing
a job that helps people become whole
um align their personal and professional
lives align and manage relationships and
um create new identities in order to uh
to meet their goals she's pursuing this
job by lying to her husband taking out
personal loan buying things she can't
afford putting herself and her husband
in some pretty significant financial
risk
um so that she can tell other people how
to live their lives with integrity
um
right
and it doesn't surprise me so I actually
work with a coach and very intentionally
this coach is not my friend
so of course it felt good to talk to
your friend who happens to be a coach
because you know what friends do friends
are like yeah
bullcrap that's what friends do right
right they swing first and then they're
like why'd we hit that guy that's what
friends do now great friends will also
say hey before I hit that dude why are
we hitting this guy
um but
they feel good that's what friends are
for supporting you up uh therapist
therapy is uncomfortable especially when
you don't like accountability and your
wife doesn't lie she doesn't like dead
man here's the deal you are you love
this woman
you also use words like hiccup
it is not a hiccup
when your wife quits therapy on you
you know what I mean that's a temper
tantrum
I'm taking my ball and I'm going home
because you said hey this is important
to us coming together here we've got
some issues she said sure I'm in and
then she's like I quit
um
you not supporting her is different than
we can't afford this those are two
different stories
right and now there's some gaslighting
going on where she's trying to make you
feel crazy
you're looking at the math and the math
says we can't afford these things
and she's going to put math aside and
say you don't like me you don't fault
right so let me ask you this is there
something beneath this layer because it
feels like there is
yeah yeah I mean um this is my first
marriage this I'm her third she's been
divorced twice I I know a little bit of
what happened and everything Carlos
brother next time you gotta lead with
that that's super that's super helpful
my bad sorry yeah I was just trying to
do the Cannonball like you said yeah you
Cannonball but you only got halfway in
like part of you hit the hit the link
when you I mean the land you jumped in
um yeah so my guess is there's a lot in
there there's a lot in there so
um and that's kind of where like I'm
trying not to get emotional but it's
kind of hard for me because right now I
feel like
like this career is definitely like it's
feeling like it's definitely above me
um
and like she's doing her thing like she
has her own agenda
um even if I ask like hey like I support
you but let's let's just wait a little
bit so we can make that money because
we're already in debt from the last time
you did this
um but she kind of just says
well if she did one time come and talk
to me about something about a purchase
that she wanted to get I told her let's
wait she's like well I'm doing it and so
I feel like she doesn't really
like respect my opinion or like respect
my I don't I don't even know what to
call it but I expect my authority yeah
yeah like it yeah it doesn't feel like
that she absolutely doesn't care
and I know this hurts to hear that
because you love her and that's your
wife
[Music]
um
but you are a springboard to the life
that she wants to lead and the moment
you try to partner up with her which is
what marriage is she says whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
I'm not doing the partner thing I'm
doing whatever the hell I want to do
right and if you don't want to be along
for that ride
hey there's two more in the shadows you
can be number three that's fine
if you don't want to get along for that
ride you're the crazy one you're the
jerk you're the not supportive one
you're the you know you're the mean guy
trying to oppress me and hold me down
um here's the old like brother you and I
could talk for a long time here
ultimately here's where the question
lies it is
um
are you in
or do you have a or what moment do you
have a line somewhere
I've been in from the start
um but with all these things happening
like I feel like that line is just
little by little Kryptonite yes to be
honest yes like I can 100 tell you I've
been in from the start I knew what I you
know was getting into I knew like her
trauma and I feel like it as it you know
as it just kept going it just got worse
and worse and worse and
I don't know it's just yeah I mean I'm
just trying to be super honest with you
like okay appreciate that brother but
it's but that line yeah you can be
turned around and somebody else can be
edging you out right
um yes the other the other thing is this
I just so we're clear I'm not just
bagging on your wife
um
dude she may have been I don't know just
a whole other conversation you're not
gonna have off like she may have been
abused in these other marriages in these
other relationships and she circled the
wagons and said this will never happen
again
and she may have hit that pendulum too
far no man will ever tell me what I can
and can't do because I paid the price
for that physically psychological I mean
who knows what that past is
the reality though is she y'all are here
right so the path forward is you sitting
down with a very clear or what moment
This is Gonna Change or I'm gonna go
or you've got to be completely honest
with yourself and say even if this
doesn't change I'm gonna stay
and then it becomes much more about
Management on your end
so let's take it and make it much less
personal for you I hear people call and
say hey my um my wife you know all these
my husband's gained 110 pounds I love
him
I'm no longer physically or sexually
attracted to him at all and I don't know
what to do
one of the starting places I always
start are you going to leave
and sometimes people like yeah I'm
really kind of getting that's one track
the other is I will never leave no
matter what I'm here ride or die
that's a different conversation see what
I'm saying right and so you've got to
ask yourself where is that line and
don't let it sneak up on you you just
got to be honest with yourself and with
your wife and say Here's what this line
is
and then you got to be really clear
about here's what getting on the same
page means that we're doing this thing
together I'm a hundred percent
guaranteeing you that her experiences as
a life coach will fail
because she's not living the principles
that she will be taught to teach other
people
and you can't oh I mean ultimately you
have to live the principles that you're
teaching right or it right and you can
you can limp and and prop it up but it's
going to fall over
right right and so ultimately you got to
say here's where we are here's what
we're going to be about and
um I need you involved
or else
have you pictured yourself or else
I have I have before okay
um I don't like to think about it I feel
guilty of doing it yeah can I ask you a
real hard question
absolutely
um
um do you have somebody else in mind
already
uh like like another person yep
no no
does she
I would say no I don't think she does
you are less confident about that answer
well it's just because
I mean I it it I don't think it was a
less confident I feel like
I feel hurt right now that I just can't
trust her so my mind's going everywhere
there you go okay okay and I'm just like
uh well I don't know I I can't trust her
right so maybe uh okay okay I'm just
saying maybe you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah no totally yeah and that's the
problem
yeah so yeah this it's a good sign then
because often I ask that question and
I'll hear a pause and then the dude will
be like yeah I work with her and that
what I don't want you to do is get to a
place where you find yourself
compromising your values
because you're you know your your home
is on fire I'd rather you just deal with
the fire and then let's make some some
adult decisions moving on so let me just
ask again what are you gonna do
what's this look like
um well I I've talked to her
um already when I've found this out and
um so I I made some plans with her and
she said it's like she's good with it so
I told her like hey
we're going to talk about this in front
of a therapist
um and we'll we'll do it that way and
we'll figure things out that's honestly
all I've had planned because
talking about this her career and she's
really sensitive to it so if I say
anything about it that might that might
she might take it wrong and it just
don't conversation just doesn't go
anywhere it sounds like your home is one
where you have to walk on eggshells in
your home in your own house
absolutely and it's true your hope
should be a place where you can drop
your shoulders and say
right I can I can exhale because we got
to walk on on an eggshell sometimes at
our jobs and sometimes with dealing with
people that are tough to deal with our
home should be the right place where we
drop our shoulders right
um yeah I I would recommend writing this
out
and that way at the first counseling
session you can tell the therapist I've
read I've written a letter and I think
in that letter you should talk about
I've lost trust and I don't feel safe in
this relationship and those are not bro
things to say those are not very
Oklahoma and masculine things to say but
they're true right right
um you could say somebody asked me if
you were cheating on me and my first
thought was no but then I thought but
maybe
right and that'd be a big old oh my gosh
can't believe you would say that about
and then it's going to be a redversion
to you and what's wrong with you
but the reality is there's just this
lack of trust and is the air we breathe
I also think it would be fair to say if
you quit therapy again I'm taking them
as a sign you're quitting on us
because we're not okay
right and I think that's a very fair
boundary for you to draw
right and I I have a quick question is
everything you're saying so
um one thing that that I guess is which
is a struggle for me too is she she
tells me she's sorry but in a in a way
she's she
like I don't know the actions don't say
it so listen listen behavior is a
language
behavior is a language
my wife can come up and say you're such
a [ __ ]
while she's hugging me and giving me a
kiss
and
her actions are way more important than
her words
and she can also say no I'm not mad
well she's slamming the cabinets right
behavior is a language
right and your wife can say whatever she
wants
but she doesn't have any respect for you
more importantly she doesn't have any
not more importantly but equally
important she has any respect for the
unity the relationship y'all have
right
um she seems to only respect whatever
the crap she wants to do in whatever
moment she wants to do it in
yeah yeah I feel like she holds this
career her coaching but hey if you take
the career away my I bet a million bucks
there's been things in the past
she's still Tupperware that Mary Kay was
going to go get another degree in
nursing it was going to do something
else this is just the latest thing to
distract herself
gotcha right and it feels good and
there's all these promises about you can
make a billion dollars and you can
become an influencer and you can and
when you're when you're first in
counseling first in coaching it feels
like a superpower like oh I know why
everybody's doing what you you don't but
it feels that way because you're
learning all the stuff so it feels good
right now
right and then she can start meeting
with clients and it's going to get messy
real fast that's just that's just a
prediction maybe I'm totally wrong maybe
she's gonna be incredible at it
um and she's maybe I don't think she's a
psychopath hopefully she's not but
um
yeah this is just the latest thing
is that is that true
no yeah no very true it's it wasn't
anything during our dating life it was
anything like you know is this just
sprung forth out of nowhere and all of a
sudden this is what she's called to do
and so so let me give you this so I was
the I graduated with a PhD I was done
with school I'm done got my little Fancy
Pants doctor degree
I was the dean of students at a law
school working with my students taking
care of people
and I really like in my guts felt like
I need to figure out what's going on
with me what's going on with my family
what's going on with my marriage what's
going on with my friends going on the
country and my students so I started
nickel and Diamond my way I just took a
free class in counseling and I rolled up
I started in the master's program and
they just rolled me up into the PHD
program
when I finally was like Hey I'm going
all in on this I'm gonna go ahead and
get a second PhD that was a very hard
season for me and my wife and we had to
calculate the finances of it all the
time of it all it was something we very
much had to do together and she wasn't
on board she didn't want me to do it
she's like you've already done this and
I felt this drive but the drive couldn't
override my responsibility I had to a
young kid to a marriage that was
struggling to finances we when we owed a
bunch of people money like it was hard
to do and so we had to navigate that
together
right see what I'm saying so I had that
thing Drive I wanted to go do this thing
and I had a path laid out for me and
still had to be an adult about how I
moved forward in it I couldn't just say
oh my gosh really and just take out a
bunch of loans and and when I and I've
come to learn this the last five or six
years and embarrassingly or four last
four or five years
if I'm starting to do something send a
text make a phone call go to a store and
my first thought is
I haven't told my wife yet or I don't
need to tell her about this I definitely
need to tell her about it
because that means I'm hiding something
right yeah uh-huh yeah I agree and so I
bought two water bottles like two nights
ago off Amazon
yeah I still read some study about the
chemicals from Plastics and I was like
did I need some glasses here it is right
look I'm sitting it's right here on my
desk
and I ordered it and I thought
we have so many water bottles my wife's
gonna kill me and dude I ordered them
anyway
and I've that's a minor thing but it's a
thing that I did knowing there was gonna
be a bigger conversation and then if I
had asked my wife about it she would
have said Hey what if we waited until we
did our next budget we had the money for
it it's not like we're broke so I didn't
go take a loan out for it but it was
just a little bitty thing I had to tell
her I'm sorry I shouldn't have ordered
yet another thing right see what I'm
saying
because I'm telling you all this you're
not crazy
and you're not weak and you're not a
[ __ ] and you're not some kind of lame
like whiny whatever and you're not
crapping on your wife's dreams or
anything like that
sounds like you're all in you just want
to be all in together with your wife and
that's that I totally support that
um and I think you're right to tell your
wife
the line the cliff for us is coming up
really quick so before it sneaks up on
us we're going to see a counselor which
I think you're super wise to do I think
the next step is to write that letter
out and there's gonna be a lot of anger
in that letter a lot of rage a lot of
frustration a lot of
um
uh
emotion and feeling in that I think
that's good and then you're going to
read that letter to her in front of the
therapist and say Here's where I am
um I'm not interested in moving forward
if you're going to continue to be a
person I can't trust
or I am going to move forward but I'm
going to get my own finances and you're
going to be like right I'm gonna have to
create this world so that I can live in
that world that nobody wants to live
like that man so
um do this let me know how that first
counseling session goes I mentioned in
the follow-up there
to everybody listening if you
I said it before I I've come to believe
infidelity is a much bigger thing than
who kissed who than who made out with
who who hooked up with who
infidelity is are am am I in this
um am I all in
and am I all in with my money I'm all in
with my finances I'm all in with being
honest am I all in with letting my needs
be heard am I all in with my actions
trying to meet my partner's needs am I
all in on My All In
do I hold things back and Fidelity has
become just such a much bigger thing to
me as I meet with couples all over the
country
people are living these really
fragmented messy marriages and then
they're going to counseling trying to
fix the anxiety or trying to fix their
frustration or trying to fix this or
that and man when you try to LIT be 17
different people at the same time it's
exhausting and it's just
melting relationships
if you're gonna be all in be all in
Fidelity is about integrity and
integrity is about is the root is the
word integer it means whole it means the
circle never stops right be all in
and if somebody that you're connected to
is not all in be willing to have the
hard uncomfortable conversation
um sooner rather than later we'll be
right back
you all know there are a lot of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too I love living in a
new home but I gotta be honest
I'm no good at buying one and that's why
I'm so thankful for people like my
friends at Churchill Mortgage Churchill
is a Ramsay trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and then I'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
oh breathe because you got an expert and
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change save yourself the headache
and call Churchill Mortgage today at
Triple Eight loan 200. trust me that's
Triple Eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement and MLS ID
1591 in MLS consumeraccess.org equal
housinglender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back um instead of
taking a third call I want to spend just
a few minutes on this thing it's kind of
blown up and I don't normally do this
right instead of being the show
um I
here's where I'm kind of uh
um struggling and so I'm just gonna be
honest and I want you to I want you to
hear my thought processes here number
one a study comes out that's
um called the serotonin theory of
depression
system out a systematic umbrella review
of The Evidence
came out
and it was a potion nature looks like uh
and it just explodes Goes Bananas and
everyone's like oh my gosh nowhere
and then like most of these things it
makes its way to the popular media press
and the popular media press is desperate
for one thing
let's not ever forget this in the
popular media press when you listen to
this show a it's free and B
um I sell ads like for a mattress
company
um I have some supplements that are
coming soon I try to tell you my book
right that's how I make my money right
so I want you to show up here
um when you're in one of the popular
news media World
um you're selling at you just want
eyeballs and somebody else is dealing
with the ads right so your whole job is
not to give correct news to not to give
right answers the whole job is to get
clicks and the more Sensational and wild
and
um I can make something
the more likely I am to click on it
and when there's something as
complicated as depression and
neurobiology and Science and you're
trying to push a narrative that science
is all screwed up and no one should
trust scientists and we should all just
sit at home and whatever
um
then this kind of thing comes out and
it's so easy to get all of your ducks in
a row in one Fell Swoop I can get all
the clicks I want by going oh my gosh
yeah and I can bash science again and
and in so here's that and then here's my
second problem I refuse to participate
in the click bait so I'm not even going
to tell you who the pundit is that's
running their mouth about this it's
probably not hard to figure out
um because this isn't a political issue
this is a somebody's talking about
something and they don't know what
they're talking about and they're going
to get a lot of people hurt
and it makes me crazy when people do
this
it makes me crazy like so if you hear me
talk about education for instance I'll
talk about hey teachers you need to let
kids talk in the lunchroom I'm not going
to complain about a problem until I got
a solution to it and now pundits have
taken this study so real quick
it's been 30 plus years if not more
decades
where scientists understood this idea
that you get depressed simply because
you are missing a particular molecule
right and the pharmaceutical industry
absolutely jumped all over this
hypothesis the serotonin myth the dope
and whatever
missing molecule myth you want to jump
to and we're gonna give you a drug that
replaces that molecule then no matter
what's going on in your life what's
going on in your environment what's
going on is going to suddenly be solved
and
so
ssris selective serotonin re-uptake
Inhibitors right does never has never
added more serotonin to your brain they
don't do that
they they
manipulate how that serotonin moves and
how it's bioavailable in your brain okay
so this idea that you take an SSRI to
get more serotonin into your body is
false that's not how that even works the
second thing or the I don't know what
number we're on the 500th thing here
is scientists have known this for a long
time
the farm industry has continued to push
it that's their deal
scientists have known for a long time
they moved from that to genetics hey we
think there may be a depression Gene
there may be an anxiety Gene here's what
everybody's come to know the last 15 20
30 years
that neurobiology matters
and genetics matter an environment
matters and personal experiences matter
so I can have 20 light switches in my
garage
and all of them turn on a different
light
but if nobody ever turns those lights on
they don't come on automatically
and people think that I've got all the
genes I've got all the light switches
that means everyone's going to have this
that's how that works
right and you can turn all the light
switches on but if the power to the box
is off if there's a a windstorm outside
or it's raining outside maybe the
electricity doesn't come on that day but
it comes on the next day right so
environment matters all this stuff
matters that's why this show is
important because we talk to individual
people going through individual things
because that's how you have to uh that's
how you have to distill it down that's
why in my book own your past you have to
talk about what happened to you because
all that stuff plays a role here in
addition to your genes in addition to
your diet in addition to how much you
move in addition to your whatever your
the serotonin and dopamine and all that
stuff in your head here's where I have a
problem
as a and this is a problem with the
media is that there is no wisdom
there's just grenades there's just
grenades there's no wisdom just grenades
and so as a scientist if you look at
this umbrella review of The Evidence
that there is no data that suggests that
low levels of Serotonin are related to
the development of depression
and also you look at the bajillions of
studies that suggest ssris help people
with depression
I personally have benefited from ssris
for anxiety and here's why did it solve
my anxiety nope I've been pretty open
about that it doesn't fix anxiety but it
takes the alarm system and helps turn it
down a bit and quite honestly I don't
care about the neurobiology it worked so
that I could go see a counselor so so
that I could have some hard hard
conversations in with my wife and my
marriage so that I could sit with some
parenting coaches so that I could go to
the gym on a regular basis because I
wasn't just pulsing with this all the
time
and so as a scientist you look at this
and you go okay I've got all these SSRI
studies that say these things do have a
statistically significant chance of
helping people
and now I just got a new piece of data
that says this by the way is 30 40 years
old it's not new at all just made its
way to the popular press
huh it's not because of this well cool
now I've got a new piece of data that
doesn't mean you don't go throw the
whole thing out and it's funny because
I'm not a medicine proponent I am all
about figure out lifestyle and
environmental and Trauma
um before you just go take meds I'm
somebody who when I go to my doctor uh
when I did take a SSRI for anxiety I
said before we do this I want to have an
end date on the calendar that you and I
agree on so that I have something to aim
for I don't want this just to be a part
of my life forever and my doctor's
response was you're gonna have to do a
lot of work then like going to
counseling and exercising and changing
your diet all those things
and I was I was up for it I was in
so all that to say is this
if you take ssris
under no circumstances should you
instantly just stop taking them don't do
that
if you uh take benzos
don't just stop taking them because some
pundit on some new show told you not to
go meet with your doctor
if you are wondering huh I want to learn
more about neurobiology neuro
neuropsychology I want to learn how
these things great there is you now have
the internet and you can find all kinds
of studies it's incredible I'll even put
a link to this in the show notes
um
also is it called a scientist
the more you partner with a
pharmaceutical company the more that you
stand the chance to have your messaging
go sideways and then this is the result
and the group that looks the worst here
is not the farm industry it's
psychiatrists
and I know some psychiatrists and they
are extraordinary people
and they help a lot a lot of people
there's also psychiatrists that are just
idiots like in every job
so what am I saying number one
everybody relax take a breath number two
don't go to
a news station for your medical needs go
talk to your doctor
and that's been a conversation for the
last three or four or five years
to my friends who are in the media stop
stop
with the big Sensational ah damn it
because you're gonna get people hurt
you're going to get people hurt because
people are going to watch that and be
like I knew it
worse parents are going to watch that
and say I knew it now my kids and
they're going to get their kids off
there is no I won't say that I'm not
gonna say that
and you can tell I'm frustrated I'm
frustrated when people who don't know
what they're talking about run their
math about something and they have
influence over a lot of people and
people are going to get hurt
oh man
um
drugs aren't the answer to every problem
they're just simply not and as a culture
and as a country we are as a Humanity we
are well overdue to reimagine how we
live life
and the pace and the scale and the scope
and the maniacal pay all of it
How We Do relationships and how we try
to have everything we need to look at
that
and also to throw out
[Music]
all medications and drugs
that's Insanity it's Madness
it's like getting rid of electricity
because of electrical fires
so there's that we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
Kelly once again
um she is oh so much older than me in it
three years people three years at least
13 years at least 13 years
um she's a big Huey Lewis in the news
fan not a big surprise though that she
her favorite Huey Lewis song is called I
want a new drug
figures figures
um the song goes like this
I want a new drug
figures Kelly one that won't make me
sick or one that won't make me crash my
car or make me feel three feet thick
I want a new drug one that won't hurt my
head one that won't make my mouth too
dry or my eyes too red one that will
make me nervous wondering what to do one
that makes me feel like I feel when I'm
with you oh
when I'm alone with you I want a new
drug one that won't spill one that won't
cost too much or come in a pill
one that won't make me nervous wondering
what to do
one that makes me feel like I feel when
I'm with you Kelly that's how I it's not
I do feel like I'm on drugs but never
mind hey we'll see you soon
[Music]